tu vas entendre un vrai truc de dingue
ou pas huawei
a mais si on s'est dit qu'on annonçait
la vie tranquillement au café si leur
dossier cools et d'un débat puisque tu
as des crédits soit stable
à merde tu es enceinte ah non non c'est
carrément pas
bon tu veux que je dise pour toi aussi
elle faisait très ou pas voilà des prêts
depuis 30 ans
j'espère qu'on explique en fait c'est
trop énorme
[Musique]
voilà les nouvelles 1
sincèrement c'est mieux de pas le dire
je pense
on y va ouais allez fais partie
j'ai plutôt avec vous faire découvrir ce
qui est à mon sens le clou de la visite
[Musique]
sauf conduit peut radicalement changer
votre vie
canton descendance conduite kwal
embrouillé avec se conduit sans
nucléaire qu'à celui parlé tétouan
canton descendance conduit madame
monsieur écoutez bien parce que c'est
vraiment quelque chose en fait il veut
quoi merde quand on descend dans ce
conduit vous n'allez pas me croire et
pourtant c'est la vérité
[Musique]
c'est juste dingue et alors c'est pas
tout
[Musique]